I remember when I was doing Saving
Private Ryan there was a scene between a
couple other guys and Spielberg moved on
and we were he was marching off to the
next kind of little place he was going
to shoot and I said Steven you know
don't you think we should have done a
couple more takes of that thing you know
because it what hadn't been great he
turned on a dime and he said I could
spend another hour on that scene and
perhaps make it 10 better or I can go do
another great shot I'm gonna do the shot
and I remember at the time feeling like
well I'm mildly offended by that you
know and I think where I am now is
exactly where he was then and and I
think that's right I've come to see it
as as a magic trick right that you're
that these hundred people have come
together to try to make work and and
it's not all about any one person's
thing it's really about the director and
how can you support the magician right
and I think the great Challenge and the
fun for me is to try to look at the
design of the movie and try to make the
performance work within the design
rather than try to make the whole thing
come to me